is there ideas how to do that is that
on the genetic engineering level
is it uh like what can you mess with is
it
going to the trying to discover the
backup copies
and restoring from them like what's if
it's it's possible to convert into
natural language words
what are the ideas here what is the
observer and how do we contact it
exactly what's the observer and how do
you contact or if there's other ideas
how to reverse the the the boss getting
lost process
yeah well you you can slow it down slow
it but we found a reset switch recently
we just published this um in the
december
2020 issue of nature and what we found
is that there are three
embryonic genes that we could put into
the adult
animal to reset the age of the tissues
and it only takes four to eight weeks to
work well and we can take a blind mouse
that's
lost its vision due to aging neurons
aren't working well towards the brain
reset those neurons back to a younger
age and now the mice can see again
these three genes are famous actually
because they're a set of four genes
discovered by shenya yamanaka who won
the nobel prize in 2016
for discovering that those four genes
when turned on
at high levels in adult cells can
generate
stem cells and this is i think well
known now that we can create stem cells
from adult
tissue but what wasn't known is can you
partially take age back without becoming
a tumor
or generating a stem cell in the eye
which would be a disaster
and the answer is yes there is a system
in the body that can take the age of a
cell back to a certain point but no
further
safely and reset the age
and we're now using that to reset the
age of the brain of those mice that we
age prematurely
and they're getting their ability to
learn back
this is really exciting right like
what's uh what's the downside
of this well the downside is if you
overdo it
and you don't get it right you might
cause tumors
but we do we do it very carefully and we
also know that in the eye it's very safe
yeah we also injected these we we
deliver them by viruses so
we can control where and when they get
turned on
and in this paper we've published that
if we put high levels in the mouse
into their veins throughout the body
they don't get cancer for over a year
so i'm so optimistic that we're going
into human studies
in less than two years from now
you